gonna start off with the dragon's nest
so the sidewalking of lily versus the
back dashing of elisa
right yeah fairly fairly good lily
let's see if he's able to continue that
streak i mean he's i mean that match
with a wise honey was crazy he was
definitely preparing for akuma is he
prepared for lisa though let's see
that's and that's the question right
mark because we've only seen him play
versus the killer so we know how good
he's at
how good is he in the in the 3d
and you know the matches that we saw
earlier with the sharp playing you know
he did very well early on in the outset
and then fate uh vidcon actually like
kind of just took that away from him we
really never got a chance to see him
play towards the extended sets but
we'll see right now he's doing great
again first round no problem
always take two but this is where it
gets tricky this is where it gets tricky
you got to close it out yeah
absolutely yeah you can't let the
momentum die
quick start up you gotta be able to
finish
kick here puts the brakes on punish
there from fgl
yep
who is this guy man like this is just so
good fgl with the knowledge there
punishment
love to see it
one of these instances where we get to
be treated to a player that again
we were not familiar with at all and
this is almost unprecedented but i don't
want to say that because i feel like
this happens almost every year we always
see a
rising star come out of nowhere to
really take out some of the best players
in the world
yeah absolutely
oh
okay
oh i had a big opportunity there
will he be able to come back here he
does have rage
this is scary
[Music]
i
very quick attack
sharp looking to take this opening match
here fgl fighting back
it's spiked
yep
that actually that head range is crazy
by the way that like it pulls up even
further later this time having the
confidence to finish the string
yeah down three keeping the pressure has
the wall oh the chainsaws were out when
i counter it was two
yo fgl is crazy he is so good at leaving
in and out of traffic fight
final round here match number one
yeah
so back and forth right now who's gonna
take this final round
but both guys are playing a lot more
patient now they're trying to pick their
shots
okay
oh
i think that was a unintentional
jump there went to the sidewalk probably
oh good adjustment
because of the aerial stage oh he almost
had the full combo but he still hit the
last part
pressing the button
the challenge
down three
oh my gosh that's not what he wanted oh
my god oh what the hell
he crushed it
i had the downboard won the defense held
up there from he shot it but
yeah just not that through the magical
movement
magical move yep
it does everything i crushed low crush
low
that's a that's a wild
either way
could have gone either way
but again we're starting to see fgl
shine even more
even more that was a close match but
again it only matters who's up who's
standing at the end and who's advancing
and fgl has been putting in work
the entire tournament we already talked
about who he beat who else is gonna be
added to that list
yeah he's trying to add names man he's
got he's got his little death note man
and he's been putting names in there man
ursuline ash he put away sonny in there
and now it's like a sharded you know
he's on his way this loser bracket run
is looking insane and i don't know why
pakistanis have been hiding this guy fgl
no one told me about him i wasn't i
wasn't told you know i wasn't kept up to
date but this guy is uh
very very strong and we're seeing it him
and the punishment mark is on point man
the movement this the the combo like
like that little uh down jab into while
signing two you know and the
adjustment on the combo he knew in that
situation that he would be able to get a
float combo just uh very very solid
stuff right now
yeah like one of them oh do you know
what what else is really crazy
another thing that's really crazy is
that it reminds me of a situation in
korea there was an online tournament
that i was commentating and cbm and
lojai were um were giving me the the
information on the players and there was
one lily player that made it into the
winners finals and i'm like who is this
guy and then obsidian messaged me back
saying we don't know
there are monsters everywhere oh my gosh
yeah
literally and it looks like even even
the pakistanis don't know who this guy
is so you better find out man because
he's about to take out a shot if you
could win one more match here we go
loser bracket action
i gotta do it proper man i gotta put
respect on his name fgl
1299-25 doing an amazing run here
big punch the follow-up here looking to
close out
[Music]
you're not pulling that off
not not on my watch yeah
this stuff
nice conversion he saw the trade
gets the wall here
not able to get the conversion doesn't
matter he has positioning but it might
be a mistake wall bounce
nice adjustment he waits
dropping at the legs do it again
one more time good measure
oh we could have got a big big riff
punish there he messed it up
oh i like it he went for the chainsaw
sidestep just to get into the right
positioning here
interrupt good breaking the throw big
whip there punish
finishes the string
what happened
fgl 12 9 9 2 5 let's go
nice check there i like that now pushing
towards the wall
has good positioning here almost had the
bounce
oh he delayed the punish he went for the
low instead shining those shoes two
rounds to one we saw this last year yes
pulled out to the lead but that fgl was
slowly closing the gap will he be able
to do it again
let's see man let's see
exactly a repeat of the last the last
match fgl
has the command of us very small lively
down three and the lows again he ain't
looking low mark
he's not he's gonna have to be careful
he's gonna have to make sure this counts
oh
nice punish
oh the rage art now i don't know if this
is gonna be dead though i don't think
it's gonna kill that's at least my call
on it it's gonna be very close has a mix
up here
what's he gonna do how is he gonna
finish it and clean his plate oh the
rage drive
fgl42069
coming for you trying to take two rounds
straight or two i mean two matches
straight will he be able to oh boy
okay right now he's on the table though
howdy that's freaky kid
oh nice catches besides stepping
no parry
oh oh
sharp fighting back offense
but fgl has a chance oh my gosh near the
wall too
careful rage available
oh oh did not believe
the punish he shot him stays alive here
in the final round we are going to a
final match here between these two
very very strong players lilly versus
elisa we're not going to be seeing any
character changes i'm sure we're going
all the way down to the y guys in this
losers quarter finals
i like to see it make it interesting
fighting back you know sharp showing
that he's not done yet not done yet this
fgl guy is good right but i'm better
i mean who could actually a loser's
bracket that's what i gotta find out i'm
gonna go look
back into the the brackets kind of
figure this out because whoever beat
this guy must be hella good
yeah like uh that was this the
tournament was stacked right and we saw
the same thing in uh the middle east
tournament last week so uh
who ended up winning the tournament he
was put into loser bracket by luffy who
is the poor player from saudi arabia he
then writes just then went on a tear and
lose a bracket beating everyone getting
his run back on luffy 2-0 and then
winning the grand finals convincingly
six to one um in uh by resetting the
bracket like sometimes people just do
that they're slow starters mark and then
when they they wake up when they're in
losers and they just start staring into
people
it happens sometimes man it's crazy fgl
man wow crazy stuff someone checked and
they mentioned it was wind gut that sent
them to losers
when god so when god actually put him in
losers and
and and he's currently in the tournament
too so if if fgl wins now and we're
going to they might run into each other
yeah
but we're going to the devil's pit and
what a fitting end for this set it's
gonna be a stage where we have walls and
then we transition onto the infinite in
the end
we have a little bit of everything here
we go
final match fight
all right into it here we go they're
swinging power crunch yeah it's gonna be
big he's gonna get the wall as well
oh my god how did he roll out of that
oh my god how did that hit
yeah
it was guaranteed to be it's still real
to me damn it oh man
give some of the root of you'll double
up
yeah you don't succeed do it again
absolutely man
i'm getting a bit greedy with those
combos jumping
there's something about
not not gonna do a ton of damage but
it's gonna do a lot of wall carry
absolutely yeah he's in the wall now
that's frames
rows more lows
he knows the situation
oh
raise your belly but be careful
be careful that's using like all of
lily's moves dude he's whipping out the
entire arsenal
yeah
definitely this kind of inside out
sharp needs this round
okay oh
god i'm just hitting him
there we go two rounds no more walls
here
let's see how you adjust oh okay this is
hitting uh oh the oaky
fgl on the tail right now guessing
correctly
yo the charm is in trouble
nice block
no launch
had an opportunity sitting just outside
the range no duck in the world one fgl
with a massive live lead on the infinite
stage two what can i shot him do
30 seconds to go
someone's gonna have to make a move
yeah he shot it fgl does not have to
overextend here
gets the knock down
you need to close it out one more hit oh
my god that's gonna hurt
oh boy
jesus
but three rounds straight
uh fgl living to fight another day he
might get his run back with the guy that
set him in the loser's record if he
keeps it up if he keeps it up
this is crazy stuff
like this is what we wanted to see we
thought it might be a little bit
predictable man like we thought okay you
know